io sono qui a parlarvi di felicità che
come potete vedere dal titolo è una cosa
seria
cominciamo prima di iniziare
letteralmente con un piccolo sondaggio
alzi la mano chi sa felice in questo
momento vedo belli carichi sono stato
contento grazie per le luci sono
convinto che la risposta sarebbe più
difficile
se io vi chiedessi quanto siete felici
io sono un economista
in particolare mi occupo di misurazione
della felicità della qualità della vita
noi economisti abbiamo una deformazione
professionale
diamo i numeri b è letteralmente diamo i
numeri nel senso che mettiamo un numero
a tutto quello che misuriamo la felicità
in economia viene associata al benessere
il benessere viene associato al denaro e
quindi normalmente la felicità in
economia viene monetizzata secondo
l'implicita equazione per cui più denaro
e più felicità sono in grado di comprare
se questa è la storia io devo farvi
un'altra domanda
una domanda che sarà fondamentale per il
resto della vostra esistenza e questa
domanda è la seguente cosa succede al
pil il prodotto interno lordo di una
nazione
se un professore sposa la sua quota
potrà sembrarvi una domanda stupida e
banale
io prometto che vi darò la risposta a
questa domanda nel corso del mio
intervento
vi posso dire che questa domanda è stata
fatta diversi anni fa da un premio nobel
per l'economia paul samuelson in una
conferenza non troppo diversa da questa
prima appunto però di arrivare alla
risposta a questa domanda io devo
raccontarvi un altra storia è questa
molti di voi sono convinto che la
conosceranno già è una storia che arriva
direttamente da siddharta di hermann
hesse della storia dell'elefante e dei
suoi saggi c'è chi in un villaggio
indiano arriva un elefante che deve
essere descritto da questi saggi che
sono ciechi quindi cosa succede a
seconda di quale la parte dell'elefante
che viene toccata l'elefante sembra una
cosa completamente diversa
l'orecchio sembra un ventaglio la coda
sembra un serpente la proboscide una
corda la zampa una colonna il corpo
dell'elefante sembra un muro tutti i
saggi e nessuno allo stesso tempo hanno
ragione perché l'elefante più della
somma delle sue componenti e con la
felicità diciamo che funziona più o meno
allo stesso modo la felicità è un
ombrello sotto cui stanno tante
dimensioni ea seconda di come noi
decidiamo di misurare la felicità
vediamo cose diverse come misura la
felicita influenza come vediamo le
società vi faccio subito un esempio
quella che vedete le mie spalle è la
classifica dei dieci paesi al mondo che
stanno meglio
secondo due indicatori molto diversi
a sinistra c'è la classifica di felicità
misurata dal world happiness report
dell'onu un'iniziativa che dal 2012
misura la felicità per i paesi nel mondo
a destra cioè la classifica secondo il
reddito medio pro capite quindi il pil
il prodotto interno lordo come vedete le
due classifiche sono molto diverse ora
la felicità ha una dimensione se
vogliamo rimanere nella metafora della
storia dell'elefante di cui viene
toccato solo un pezzo come si misura in
parte vi ho già risposto
l'indicatore principe utilizzato per
misurare la felicità una dimensione è il
prodotto interno lordo
e che cos'è il prodotto interno lordo
questa è la definizione dal libro di
testo si definisce come il valore dei
beni e servizi finali prodotti in
un'economia in un certo intervallo di
tempo che normalmente è un anno
cerchiamo di andare un po più dentro
questa definizione
allora valore ci dice subito che il pil
è misurato in moneta
secondo qual è la valuta del paese che
si sta considerando beni e servizi e ci
dice che il pil comprende beni materiali
ma anche servizi per esempio una cena un
ristorante finale è molto importante
immaginate un paese in cui ci sono
soltanto due aziende una produce
automobili e una produce acciaio quella
che produce automobili usa l'acciaio
prodotta dalla seconda azienda
nel pil finisce a essere contato
soltanto il reddito che deriva dalla
vendita delle automobili perché in
questo caso l'acciaio è un bene
intermedio e finirebbe con l'essere
contato due volte
ora il pil il prodotto interno lordo è
un po sulla bocca di tutti ea buona
ragione perché ha degli aspetti positivi
e delle criticità da un punto di vista
positivo è un ottimo indicatore di
prosperità economica
cosa significa che è una fotografia
un'istantanea molto precisa della salute
produttiva di un paese in un certo
istante di tempo
inoltre il pil ha il pregio di essere
sintetico un numero solo rende molto
semplici confronti tra paesi diversi e
per lo stesso paese lungo la dimensione
temporale
infine il pil è associato positivamente
ha dimensioni che noi normalmente
consideriamo correlate alla qualità
della vita
cosa vuol dire che paese con un pil piu
elevato normalmente sono paesi in cui le
persone sono più sane sono più istruite
e la qualità delle istituzioni e
migliore va tutto bene sì e no perché ci
sono anche delle criticità
la prima è che il pil è come se fosse la
busta paga di una nazione
niente di male ma voi dite di una
persona che è ricca solo guardando la
sua busta paga
non penso infatti se andate in banca a
chiedere un prestito la banca non si
accontenterà mai solo della vostra busta
paga vuole conoscere la vostra
situazione patrimoniale e il pil invece
non misura la situazione patrimoniale di
un paese è una è un flusso di produzione
in secondo luogo il pil e questo fu
detto in un celeberrimo discorso di bob
kennedy nel 1968 esclude dal suo computo
alcune variabili che sicuramente
producono valore per la nostra esistenza
ma non sono monetizzate il gioco dei
nostri bambini la bellezza delle nostre
poesie non sono incluse nel pil eppure
producono valore e fanno una vita felice
viceversa il pil include al suo interno
delle variabili che sono monetizzate che
però è difficile pensare siano associate
un miglioramento della qualità della
vita
una su tutte la spesa per divorzi se una
coppia si separa e deve pagare un
avvocato divorzista quel reddito diventa
pil però è opinabile che la fine di un
amore possa essere visto come il
miglioramento di ricchezza di un paese
ora questo mi consente di farvi vedere
questo grafico che mostra quanto la
relazione tra reddito e felicità sia una
cosa complessa questo grafico arriva da
una ricerca di metà anni settanta di un
ricercatore americano richard easterlin
che mostrò sostanzialmente la relazione
tra reddito pro capite medio per i paesi
del mondo e felicità misurata secondo
questionari in cui si chiede alle
persone quanto sono felici in una scala
da 1 a 10
quello che si vede da questo grafico e
che all'aumentare del reddito la
felicità aumenta ma arrivati a una certa
soglia
la felicità non cresce proporzionalmente
con il reddito cioè come un livello di
saturazione oltre il quale la relazione
tra reddito e felicità non è così
lineare questo produce dei paradossi
questi paradossi sono diversi e uno ha
reso l'italia celebra nel 2014 perché lì
stato l'ufficio statistico nazionale ha
vinto è stato insignito del
prestigiosissimo premio ignobel per
l'economia lo sto scherzando che ogni
anno viene assegnato dalla
prestigiosissima università di harvard
perché è stato dato il premio nobel per
l'economia all'istat per che recependo
una direttiva comunitaria l'istat ha
stabilito che nel pil italiano vanno
contati i proventi redditi che derivano
dal traffico di stupefacenti ed al
mercato della prostituzione
ora significa che il più del pil
associato a queste attività viene
identificato come un miglioramento della
ricchezza ma è opinabile che queste
attività siano associate a un
miglioramento della qualità della vita
di un paese
il secondo paradosso mi permette
finalmente di rispondervi alla domanda
da cui sono partito cosa succede al pil
di una nazione quando un professore
sposa la sua quota
partiamo dall'inizio
un professore assume una cuoca deve
essere molto ricco questo professore e
se la assume le farà un contratto
regolare le pagherà uno stipendio quello
stipendio e reddito entrerà nel pil nel
prodotto interno lordo come un flusso
positivo
i due si innamorano e se desiderano
coronare il loro sogno d'amore
sposandosi per esempio è auspicabile che
il professore rompa il contratto con sua
moglie e se lo rompe quella non è più
una transazione non è più reddito e
quindi il pil è associato un segno meno
ma la domanda è possibile che in questo
caso la nascita di un amore venga
misurata come un peggioramento della
qualità della vita di una nazione
ora scena felicità una dimensione
presenta alcune criticità che abbiamo
visto come si fa a misurare la felicità
più dimensioni qui prima abbiamo
criticato l'istat
per il premio nobel per l'economia ora
invece viene tacerne le lodi per cari
stati all'avanguardia in europa con un
progetto che dal 2013 vuole integrare la
contabilità nazionale attraverso un
diverso approccio alla misurazione del
benessere questo progetto si chiama best
desse un acronimo che sta per benessere
equo e sostenibile e in sostanza
l'obiettivo è quello di misurare il
benessere di una nazione non più con un
solo numero
il reddito ma con un sistema di
indicatori sono 134 raccolti lungo 12
dimensioni che sono quelle che vedete
alle mie spalle
all'interno delle quali c'è anche il
reddito ma ce ne sono molte altre
c'è la salute c'è l'istruzione c'è il
lavoro ci sono le relazioni sociali la
politica la sicurezza il benessere
soggettivo il paesaggio l'ambiente la
ricerca la qualità dei servizi
ora come nella storia dell'elefante
tutte queste dimensioni compongono il
benessere ma non una indipendentemente
dalle altre io conclude il mio
intervento citandovi un'altra ricerca
che è diventata celebre perché è stata
pubblicata da due premi nobel per
l'economia
daniel cane ma ne angus deaton
che hanno utilizzato dei dati americani
della gallo per studiare la relazione
tra reddito e felicità e stimare la
soglia critica cioè qual è quel numero
magico cui reddito oltrepassato il quale
il reddito non compra più la felicità
questo numero magico per gli stati uniti
e identificato stimato essere 75 mila
dollari annui oltre il quale reddito la
felicità non si muove più con il reddito
all'aumentare della ricchezza non
aumenta la felicità e la domanda con cui
vi lascio è questa siamo in grado noi di
stimare la nostra soglia critica oltre
alla quale il reddito non compra più la
felicità io credo e spero di sì
e con questa speranza è questa
convinzione e con questa bellissima
vignetta dei peanuts
vi auguro di essere vergognosamente
felici grazie